[Musique]
d'informations locales sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 25 janvier voici les
titres de ce journal enfin dans l'espace
saluer ce que ça t'a été mise en orbite
hier depuis la floride après plusieurs
reports de la date du lancement est
développée au latmos aux nano satellites
sera dédié à l'observation du soleil et
de la terre pour constater notamment l'
influence de l'éclairement de l'étoile
sur le climat et nous avons pu suivre
l'événement laboratoire installé à
guyancourt
ils sont 12 dans les yvelines les
députés en plusieurs missions dont celle
de voter les lois focus dans cette
édition sur la participation de nos
parlementaires dans l'hémicycle avec un
invité philippe benassaya nous
reviendrons également avec l'élu sur sa
question au gouvernement de la semaine
dernière elle portait sur le projet de
loi sur le séparatisme enfin cette
initiative à gaz rend ce week end une
société nantaise proposé d'adopter des
poules pondeuses les volatiles étaient
destinés à l'abattoir 450 ont pu ainsi
trouver une nouvelle famille et puis ce
partenariat entre l'ile-de-france et la
gendarmerie pour garantir la sécurité au
sein des transports la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse
est venue présenter le dispositif
vendredi dernier c'était à villiers
saint frédéric
son lancement initial était prévue le 16
décembre après plusieurs reports la
fusée falcon 9 de space x enfin décoller
depuis cap canaveral en floride à son
bord lu vs cussac ce nano satellites a
été élaboré par le latmos à guyancourt
il sera dédié à l'observation du soleil
et de la terre
retour sur ce lancement avec justin
brasier 143 satellite viennent d'être
mis en orbite le plus grand nombre de
sept et dit jamais envoyé en une seule
fois
parmi eux deux satellites du latmos dont
un sous pavillon français lui vécu ça tu
ici ce qui est un petit peu nouveau
c'est qu'effectivement on a on a tout
fait de a à z tout c'est une certaine
fierté parce que du coup cessé toutes
les équipes qui sont concernés tous les
laboratoires toute l'université nos
tutelles le cnrs nous deux universités
voilà qui nous ont aidés si le nano
satellites devaient initialement partir
le 16 décembre dernier les différents
reports dus aux conditions météo et
problèmes techniques n'ont pas inquiéter
l'équipe dès qu'il ya un petit problème
technique que ces vérifications et on
attend leur feu vert pour reprendre
lancé donc non pour nous c'était c'était
plutôt bien ces retards par contre
effectivement en une fois que là je le
faisais par là c'est là où la tension
est l'atout grande parce que c'est là où
tout peut arriver pour notre santé la
fusée falcon nine a finalement décollé
ce dimanche depuis la base de lancement
de cap canaveral en floride
le lancement a lieu à 16 heures heure de
paris une heure plus tard le nano
satellites uvs q7 était en orbite
la mission a franchi les étapes
critiques on a déjà au démarrage la la
propulsion de la fusée et on va un
moment atteindre un niveau de puissance
maximum donc entre 0 et 10 secondes
c'est le niveau le plus contraignant au
niveau des instruments lors de la mise
en orbite
alors une autre étape c'est l'état du
climat et là on était dans une situation
particulière où il y avait une certaine
vitesse de vent qui était supérieure à
20 km/heure donc ça peut créer du
cisaillement au niveau de la fusée
chacun des satellites a été éjecté
individuellement et mis en orbite avec
succès et reste à savoir si le nano
satellites a survécu aux différentes
étapes pour nous aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est d'avoir la communication
le signe qu'il est vivant et dont on
attend un signal une émission de ce
satellite pour voir qu'il est bien
vivant
un signal reçu dimanche soir confirmant
sa viabilité et la réussite de la
mission coût global de la mission 3
millions d'euros en ce début de semaine
focus dans ce journal sur les missions
de nos députés la première laquelle on
pense forcément c'est celle de voter les
lois mais ce n'est pas la seule mission
de nos députés justement alors qu'elle
est à l'activité nos parlementaires on
en parle avec un invité philippe
benassaya
bonsoir soir députés à l'est républicain
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
on parle avec vous notamment dans un
instant de votre travail au sein de la
commission spéciale qui porte sur le
projet de loi séparatisme vous avez
d'ailleurs posé une question au
gouvernement sur ce sujet c'était la
semaine dernière également sediag à
tsonga de la rédaction de tv soit 118
avec nous en plateau bonsoir ça avec
vous on va voir les chiffres justes en
de la participation de nos députés yves
binois au vote
oui alors la participation au vote des
députés mesure à la présence en
hémicycle
alors comme vous pouvez voir sur cette
infographie michel de vaucouleurs député
modem de la 7e circonscription arrive en
tête de taux de participation au vote
avec 35% et en fin de liste c'est michel
vialay députés l ère de la 8e
circonscription avec 7% pourriels brawn
qui v
chiffre s'explique par l'activité du
député qui est varié la présence dans
l'hémicycle et le vote dans l'hémicycle
est vraiment qu'un une faible 1 qu'un
faible indice de notre activité est
beaucoup plus large que cela et je crois
que c'est ça qu'il faut vraiment que les
citoyens comprennent alors philippe
benassaya vous vous avez un taux de 13 %
de participation au fait pourquoi alors
d'abord je vais employer un mot que vous
connaissez très bien ce genre de
classement ce sont des marronniers voilà
chaque année on fait un classement des
magots antiparlementaire qui consiste à
dire les députés ne sont pas présents
dans l'hémicycle et il ne vote pas les
loin ça se passe pas du tout comme ça
faudra qu'un jour quelqu'un leur
explique
parce que comme ça on en sort et puis on
n'est pas obligé de se justifier que ce
soit les députés droite d'ailleurs ou de
gauche c'est la même chose
un député d'un travail en hémicycle dans
lequel il vote soit de manière
électronique avec un bouton pour contrer
abstention soit à main levée la majorité
des projets de loi c'est à dire les
projets du gouvernement
c'est à main levée donc ce n'est pas
comptabilisable deuxième point on ne
peut pas être en hémicycle toute la
journée sur tous les projets de lois qui
sont votées musique sinon on passerait
du lundi au dimanche toute la journée et
la soirée et la nuit en hémicycle donc
moins de temps sur le terrain mais ne
manquent pas sauter - temps en
commission spéciale - temps en
commission tout court - le temps au
groupe d'études - temps rendez-vous
maintenant en commission des finances
comme je le suis mais en ce moment c'est
impossible
notre bureau n'est pas dans l'hémicycle
et puis par exemple il va y avoir un
projet de loi sur la maltraitance des
animaux probablement je ne serai pas en
hémicycle parce que ce n'est pas ma
commission ça ne dépend pas de la
commission des finances où est ce que
veut dire on ne peut pas être tout le
temps à 577 dans l'hémicycle c'est
impossible
est ce que quelqu'un peut m'aider à cela
on vous comprend bien c'est qu'on peut
pas avoir un taux de 91 ans et attend si
vous avez vu vos chiffres on est tous
entre 30 10 15
parce que chacun vote moi j'ai voté le
projet de loi de finances puisque le
show comme ils sont la commission des
finances
mais on était une cinquantaine une
centaine dans l'hémicycle sur le
séparatisme on va peut-être en parler on
ait une certaine aussi le travail du
député se fait sur le terrain lors du
salon célia est ce qu'il ya un moment
plus important qu'un autre pour aller
voter dans l'hémicycle et bien justement
à vous enlève les avait un peu répondu à
la question est bien ou ce qui justifie
la présence d'un député dans l'hémicycle
c'est notamment lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
texte qui relève de la compétence de la
commission à laquelle vous appartenez un
indicateur de présence dans l'hémicycle
c'est le sujet du texte vous ne pouvez
pas être partout nous nous spécialisons
chaud dans des thématiques et donc en
fonction des sujets vous serez présent
ou pas dans l'hémicycle une question si
tu reviens célia c'est ce que les
députés votent en fonction de son
appartenance politique ou en fonction de
sa conviction personnelle et bien
souvent c'est un mélange des deux mais
pourriels brune qui y est il y a une
liberté de vote pour les députés devant
avoir un groupe et une majorité solide
au service des français
ces facteurs de stabilité stabilité de
nos institutions
mais cela n'empêche nullement de porter
sa voix de porter ses convictions que ce
soit envers l'exécutif inverse le groupe
et dans l'hémicycle quand cela est
nécessaire
rappelons qu'un député a trois missions
principales voter la loi contrôler
l'action du gouvernement et évaluer les
politiques publiques
merci c'est bien pour toutes ces
précisions fille bénatia vous qui êtes
maintenant l'assemblée nationale depuis
presque quatre mois vous avez été élu
fin septembre dans la 10e
circonscription des yvelines à la suite
d'une législative partielle quel est le
le premier bilan que vous faites dans
votre activité justement de député dans
le classement qu'on a vu mon pourcentage
ne comprend que les quatre mois via
député jeu j'ai déjà fait pas mal en
quatre mois puisque j'ai déposé deux
propositions de loi l'une sur
l'obligation d'avoir une police
municipale dans les villes de plus de 10
mille habitants et une autre sur les
centres de supervision urbain je
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais
surtout mon activité
et concentrés sur la commission spéciale
sur le séparatisme voilà donc je suis
membre et j'étais orateurs de mon groupe
ça m'a pris énormément de temps là aussi
ça pas été comptabilisés dommage mais gm
a pris beaucoup beaucoup de temps
notamment ce week end pour faire valoir
les positions de son groupe sur ce sujet
et puis il ya tout le travail que je
découvre puisque j'étais maire et donc
je ne connaissais pas ce métier là mais
tout le travail en commissions les
travers le travail des amendements qui
sont très très compliqué puisqu'il faut
déposer des amendements article après
article
et puis aussi le travail riquet son
gouvernement j'ai déjà posé deux qui
sont au gouvernement sur concrètement
c'est déjà beaucoup
par rapport à l'activité d'autres
députés voilà c'est ainsi
alors moi j'ai tendance à dire que le
député j'ai l'impression d'être
retourner à la fac
voilà donc je suis à l'assemblée je
prends des notes j'examine jeudi sione
je pose des questions je participe à
plein de groupes de travail je passe
d'un amphithéâtre un autre amphithéâtre
entre guillemets c'est un peu ce travail
là vous l'avez rappelé le travail d'un
député c'est faire la loi d'abord c'est
à dire on a un projet de loi du
gouvernement
on est là pour l'améliorer l'amendé et
le voter ce projet de loi qui est en ce
moment examiné en tout cas il sera
examiné à partir du 1er février en ce
sens puis vous avez travaillé sur ce
sujet lors d'une commission spéciale sur
ce texte sur pour lutter contre le
séparatisme vait fait partie de cette
commission spéciale et vous avez posé on
le voit à l'image une question au
gouvernement la semaine dernière sur sur
ce sujet on en écoute un extrait ce même
le titre du projet de loi dont
commençons l'examen il fait plus
référence
ça commençait plutôt bien mais à
l'arrivée tous les sujets essentiels ont
été gommés à la place un texte qui omet
soigneusement d'aborder les principaux
ferment du séparatisme l'immigration le
voile le monde carcéral pourtant premier
producteur de séparatisme et premier
foyer de radicalisme en france
ce parti pris et politique strictement
politique
on rappelle juste le contexte c'est le
discours sur le séparatisme d' emmanuel
macron qui a eu lieu le 2 octobre
dernier c'était tôt aux mureaux et donc
ce projet de loi qui en dés
houle finalement on n'a pas appelé ça le
projet de loi sur le séparatisme et pour
plus tôt le projet de loi comportant les
principes de la république pourquoi
cette question au gouvernement et
pourquoi parler justement d'un parti
pris politique parce qu'on était parti
justement d'un discours d' emmanuel
macron mureaux qui était plutôt
ambitieux courageux en dénonçant le
séparatisme dans notre pays et le
radicalisme d'ailleurs c'est la première
fois qu'on entendait parler du mot
séparatisme qui donne une notion quand
même deux communautés qui se sépare de
la communauté nationale ce qui est très
important quand même et puis on arrive
un projet de loi plutôt de je dirais de
robinet d'eau tiède c'est à dire que le
titre a bougé on ne fait plus référence
au radicalisme au séparatisme à la
laïcité aux voiles pour en faire un en
même temps un projet en même temps c'est
à dire on essaie un petit peu de bouger
au niveau technique qu'au niveau
politique mais n'est pas énormément le
jeu gouvernement va pas assez loin
non ils gagnent pas assez loin et je
trouve que pourquoi j'ai dit que c'était
un projet de loi strictement politique
comme on l'a vu dans l'extrait c'est
qu'en fait on nous dit que le nouveau
monde
c'est le monde de la construction de la
cogestion on dépasse les partis
politiques on essaie de faire avant de
se rassembler sur des projets et en fin
de compte quand on dépose des
amendements et bien la majorité de nos
abonnements sont supprimés donc c'est
bien un projet la politique chacun
revient dans sa sphère politique pour
pouvoir défendre son projet et je trouve
ça regrettable sur un sujet qui concerne
en fait tous les français lorsque vous
avez dit on l'a pas vu dans cet extrait
aussi c'est que a est à peu près 25% des
amendements déposés par le groupe et
l'eire qui ont été rejetées voire plus
peut-être même maintenant on en est à
30% ce qui est beaucoup
on a eu à les global mans quatre ou cinq
amendements prix du groupe et l'air sur
le millier d'amendements du projet de
loi
manque de concertation ne sert pas
seulement écoute membres de
rassemblement manque de construction sur
un projet en fait j'ai l'impression que
ce projet de loi est un peu le symbole
de ce qu'est la macro ni aujourd'hui
c'est à dire beaucoup de communication
beaucoup de de discussions de dialogue
mais très peu de choses concrètes au
niveau politique
j'aurais aimé que le président de la
commission spéciale et les ministres en
question c'est à dire messieurs darmanin
dupond moretti et blanc caire qui sont à
peu près des responsables de cette de
cette loi aurait dû dire écoutée sur ce
projet de loi on doit être tous ensemble
pour pouvoir défendre la république je
le regrette justement le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin vous a
répondu on écoute le sujet c'est
l'extension du service public et du
principe de neutralité aux délégations
de transport aux piscines êtes vous
contre considérez vous que c'est une
mesure qui est négative et qui n'a pas
dû bien la république
pas de subvention à ceux qui font la
subversion retour la république pour la
première fois nous inscrirons dans la
loire dissolution des lieux de culte et
des associations
en dehors des liens que terrorisme et
pour lutter contre le séparatisme
déclarations et opposition des
financements qui viennent de l'étranger
tout le monde en a parlé personne ne l'a
jamais fait nous le faisons à la suite
du discours des murs aux fins d
certificat de virginité pénalisation de
la polygamie fin des mariages forcés qui
en compte deux cent mille personnes qui
que les et mariage forcé dans notre
république et nous avons mesdames et
messieurs d'éviter encore plein de
discussion à faire parce que 1500 un
moment hier en commission spéciale
et dire que les débats sont troqués
n'est pas monsieur le député être fidèle
au bon esprit qui a régné hier soir
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin une petite
réaction à ce que l'on vient d'entendre
philippe benassaya
oui alors c'est que vous avez remarqué
que c'était très technique d'abord les
certificat de virginité dont il parle
c'est moins d'amendements
c'est mon abonnement qui stipule que
tout étranger sur territoire français
qui demande d'un certificat de virginité
doit être expulsé le ministre d'arman a
en effet retenu l'idée donc c'est pas
c'est pas la sienne premièrement mais
monsieur darmana est très fort en
communication
oui ces techniques mais les grands
projets qui doivent conforter les
principes républicains sont absents
est-ce qu on est pour ou contre le voile
des fillettes
on irait pour bien un moment qui a été
rejetée ont rejeté ce ne sera pas dans
ce cas
le sens pas pas dans le projet de loi
est ce qu'on estime que le voilement
d'une fillette est une volonté
personnelle ou une obligation on voit
très bien que c'est une obligation sur
la laïcité il ya réduit tous le monde
carcéral qui m'intéresse avec une maison
d'arrêt sur la bord cinq communes de
bonheur signal il n'y a plus rien tsonga
sert alors que c'est le premier foyer de
radicalisme
il n'y a rien sur le séparatisme en
général il n'y a rien sur les hôpitaux
ni récents les universités donc mais ces
derniers a retenu les trois ou quatre
années qui sont bonnes d'ailleurs sur 51
article je rappelle qu'il ya cinquante
et un article sur le projet de loi
il a retenu probablement les deux ou
trois qui contenait quoi est ce que
malgré ces réserves projet de loi je le
rappelle qui sera examiné en séance
publique à partir du 1er février ce que
vous voterez pour en l'état je ne
voterai pas en l'état je voterai pas
pour jeudi bien en l'état française a
son importance
s'il est améliorée en séance puisque
vous savez qu'on passe d'abord aux
commissions et ensuite on passe en
séance en hémicycle 6 en séance le
projet est amendée améliorée et nos
amendements sont repris on votera pour
bien évidemment mais en l'état ne reste
avec mme philippe benassaya j'ai une
dernière question à vous poser sur la
situation sanitaire ducobu 19 voici
d'ailleurs est les derniers chiffres de
l'épidémie dans les yvelines sur une
semaine avec deux tendances qui se
dégagent ou le voyais des contaminations
qui repartent à la hausse + 30 pour le
taux d'incidence est à dire pour le
nombre de nouveaux contaminée pour
100000 habitants le taux de positivité
est également en légère hausse et de
l'autre côté des chiffres hospitalier à
la baisse sur une semaine on dénombre 70
patients en moins dans les
établissements du département 45
personnes étaient toujours hier dimanche
en réanimation depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1184 personnes sont
décédées du coronavirus dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois par ailleurs nous
avons appris ce week-end qu'un cluster a
été détectée sur le campus d' hec à
jouy-en-josas 19 cas de colis 19 ont été
décelées sur place après des tests
massif mené dans l'école de commerce
certains du d'ailleurs aux variants
britannique de nouveau dépistage sont
menées en ce moment en attendant les
étudiants présents sont confinés sur le
campus
philippe benacin l'on parle d'ailleurs
de plus en plus cette semaine de
nouvelles annonces qui pourraient être
faites pour contrer notamment
mais rj ans de ce variant britannique et
ça c'est l'une des principes des mesures
qui pourraient être annoncées c'est
celle d'un troisième confinement alors
on ne sait pas s'il sera un confinement
du ravec fermeture ou pas des écoles
est-ce que d'après vous déjà on doit en
arriver là
à votre avis or j'ai toujours dit que le
confinement était le recours ultime le
recours par défaut on confine parce
qu'on n'a pas d'autre solution
c'est le cas en france lorsqu'on a mal
isolés mal tester mal vaccinés
il ne reste plus que le confinement pour
pouvoir régler le problème en espérant
en croisant les doigts que le virus ne
se communique lui ne se transmet plus
grasse confinement donc ces tables c'est
un recours par par défaut je vois
surtout les autres pays qui vaccinent
énormément des pays comme israël
l'allemagne
voilà ça ça en asie bien sûr ou en
amérique
ça ça vaccine beaucoup en france on a un
retard surtout en un retard depuis le
début et on a beau interroger les
ministres et notamment ministre de la
santé pour savoir pourquoi notre pays
qui était soi disant la pointe de la
recherche de la santé et dont on vantait
le système social et c'est pourquoi ce
pays est en retard
alors forcément le confinement c'est le
dernier le dernier recours on y va
probablement on y verra un confinement
je ne sais pas quelle sauce on sera
on sera mangé puisque je ne suis pas
dans la majorité qui est dans les petits
papiers mais je pense qu'on y arrive
dans ce confinement qui sera peut-être
partiel ou global je n'en sais rien mais
au bout d'un moment on va pas multiplier
les confinements il va bien falloir
trouver des solutions rapides pouvoir
éviter le profil mans et sortir de la
crise sanitaire
mais c'est demain c'est l'un des
scénarios en tout cas évoqués qui est
sur la table en ce moment une décision
pourrait être prise à l'issue du conseil
de défense qui est prévue mercredi merci
philippe benassaya ci est revenu en
bretagne aux députés les républicains de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines
transport dans le reste de l'actualité
pour renforcer la sécurité dans les bus
et trains ile-de-france mobilité la
gendarmerie ont noué un partenariat en
plus de la sûreté ferroviaire
les gendarmes pourront effectuer des
patrouilles la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse s'est
rendue vendredi dernier à sa vie et
saint frédéric et versailles pour
dévoiler la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositifs astrid bergès renforcer la
sécurité dans les transports franciliens
c'est l'objectif du nouveau dispositif
mis en place entre ile-de-france
mobilité et la gendarmerie
il s'ajoute à celui déjà existant avec
la sûreté ferroviaire
il y avait des partenariats qui
existaient notamment avec la sncf
nous étions déjà présents depuis de très
longtemps sur ces sur ces vecteurs là on
les a densifié
on a eu la possibilité avec la région
ile-de-france de monter ce partenariat
est donc très clairement on vient
apporter un complément dans notre
dispositif à la sécurisation des
franciliens ces patrouilles
supplémentaires permettront donc
d'améliorer la sécurité globale à bord
des transports mais aussi sur les quais
et dans les gares ou partenariat que
nous avons contracté avec la région ile
de france nous permet de mettre en place
mais il pas trop lui par an sur les bus
des mille-pattes routes par an sur sur
le vecteur ferrer les patrouilles auront
lieu majoritairement dans les quatre
départements de la grande couronne dans
les yvelines
ce dispositif permet d'avoir des agents
mobiles sur tout le territoire
quand on a mis en place ce partenariat
on l'a mis en place parce qu'on voulait
qu'ils aient aucun trou dans la raquette
aucun endroit qui soit oublié c'est vrai
qu'on avait mis de la vidéoprotection
dans les bus mais la présence humaine
c'est aussi indispensable n'y a pas que
la vidéo il ya aussi besoin de personne
sur le terrain
le but est de rassurer les voyageurs et
d'empêcher les actes de violence et
d'incivilités dans les bus grande
couronne n'y a pas forcément beaucoup de
faits de violence qui se produisent mais
il peut y avoir aux heures creuses
le soir un sentiment d'insécurité et ça
eh bien on ne peut pas le laisser les
puits par ailleurs il y avait aussi des
incivilités et on voit bien que dès
qu'il ya des gendarmes qui arrive va les
incivilités s'arrête
ce dispositif est financé par
l'ile-de-france mobilité il coûtera près
d'un million quatre cent mille euros en
bientôt un nouveau visage pour le
quartier du bel air à saint germain en
laye là le chantier de la dalle
frontenac a démarré il s'agit de la
première étape d'un projet plus basse de
rénovation et de végétalisation de ce
désormais écoquartier l'idée est de
créer des espaces de convivialité pour
les habitants un projet à hauteur de 2,5
millions d'euros avec cinq cent mille
euros financés par la région ile de
france
vendredi la ville et la région
d'ailleurs inauguré officiellement le
début des travaux
propos recueillis sur place par michael
et demi d'euros
c'est une journée importante et
symbolique aussi parce que à travers ce
premier coup de pioche ou de démolition
on voulait montrer voilà le début d'un
projet de reconquête reconquête de nos
dalle dans le quartier du bel air un
quartier historique de la ville la place
des rotondes qui a été la première dalle
et puis maintenant la dalle frontenac
cette école désaffectée maternelle qui
va demain
devenir un jardin végétalisée un très
bel espace public au coeur d'une d'une
cité qui a parfois été un petit peu
compliqué à gérer mais voilà c'était
histoire de montrer aussi cette
reconquête qui commence dès aujourd'hui
et c'est un projet qu'on a beaucoup aidé
à la région avait les pécresse on l'a
cette priorité défi 2010 est de vraiment
accéléré sur la revégétalisation de
l'île de france c'est une région assez
urbaine même si on ignore souvent qui a
25 % des terres qui sont forestière et
donc à végétaliser mais voilà à portée
de la verdure dans tous les quartiers
d'île de france quel qu'il soit c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
pour nous la retraite plutôt que
l'abattoir ce samedi la société poule
pour tous proposés aux yvelinois
d'acheter des poules pondeuses à gaz
rend mille volatiles pouvait être ainsi
adopté ces gallinacés étaient destinés à
l'abattoir mélanie poquet eléonore
sinoquet pour le sujet elles sont tout
jeune retraité s'est lui poule vont
passer quelques années chez marie et
pascal c'est yvelinois viennent de les
adopter et leur ont évité l'abattoir en
bretagne où le but c'est évidemment
d'avoir des offrait au quotidien le fait
qu'elle soit bien aussi ça nous
intéressait on habite en vallée de
chevreuse donc côté écologique on a un
poulailler de luxe dans leur terrain
pour aller gambader
de leur côté sans abîmer au jardin à
côté une initiative de poule pour tous
depuis trois ans l'entreprise nantaise
propose aux saveurs de leur confier leur
poule à 18 mois les gallinacés pour
moins souvent les professionnels
renouvellent leur élevage
l'éleveur prend contact avec nous nous
on récupère la date de réforme donc
d'abattage que qui a été prévu pour cet
élevage et on fait des actions en amont
pour sensibiliser la population qui est
autour dans un premier temps et ensuite
s'il reste des poules on va aller un
petit peu plus loin les gallinacés et
est issu d'un élevage de plein air en
bretagne lors de cette opération
organisée à gaz rend 450 voulons trouver
une nouvelle famille du sport avant de
vous laisser avec peut-être un exploit à
la voile en perspective louis burton est
en bonne position pour espérer remporter
le vendée globe est le skipper de
rambouillet 11e il ya seulement un mois
fait désormais la course en tête il est
aux prises avec charlie dalin qui le
devance pour le moment légèrement 97% de
la course à la voile autour du monde a
été désormais effectuer arrivée prévue
ce mercredi aux sables d'olonne où
seront d'ailleurs sur place pour vous
faire vivre cet événement avec on
l'espère une victoire d'un yvelinois sur
l'everest des mers
cette information est bien d'autres
encore développé dans un instant
l'émission le 7-8 sport présentée par
michael et demi d'euros qui arrive sur
tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité on se quitte
avec ces images
la neige qui a fait son retour ce
week-end dans les yvelines images de
justin brasier dans le parc des sources
de la bière à guyancourt belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]